welcome back to 8701 so in this lecture
we talk about nuclear fusion
and what remember fusion is the energy
production by two light nuclei fusing
together to produce a heavier one
which is more tightly bound and again we
can understand this
from the empirical mass formula
okay so the difficulty in nuclear fusion
is that we
now have to overcome the coulomb barrier
from the other side
so we have to bring two light nuclei
together
have to overcome the coulomb barrier in
order to form
this tabular heavier and more tidally
bound state
um you might think that you can just
take a beam
two beams of protons like we do at lhc
bombard them
and create heavier
heavier nuclei but the problem is that
most of the nuclei will scatter
elastically
and will not lead to the a newborn state
so the practical way to overcome the
coulomb barrier is to by
creating
a confined mixture and supplying heat
such that
the thermal energy is enough to overcome
the coulomb barrier now you can estimate
how much energy is needed
if you for example assume a coulomb
barrier of
about 5 mev this implies temperatures
of 5 times 10 to the 10 kelvin
okay so that's really really hot right
um if you compare this to typical
temperatures
within stars you'll find that those are
only
10 to the 8th kelvin
so now you ask why does it still work
why do we
see fusion within a stellar medium
and the answer to this is again quantum
tunneling
and to some degrees also the fact that
when we have
a medium of a specific temperature the
kinetic energy of
the particle involved follows a mixture
of energy distribution
so you find some particles which have
enough energy
to overcome the coulomb potential even
so the mean value
would be below the processes within the
sun
[Music]
they are dominated by a so-called proton
proton cycle or ppi cycle
and this happens in in a number of steps
you start with
hydrogen or protons you know
the core of the sun is basically a
plasma so we can
forget about electrons in this context
so we have
two protons fusing together to
deuteron which is a proton and a neutron
via the weak interaction
here you find for the first time again
the
neutrinos being produced from the sun
then you supply
the deuterium again um and together with
the proton
you are able to produce a helium and
then the helium
again is being used to supply the third
step in this
helium-3 supplied to produce helium-4
so this is then the end product is a
helium-4 here
and energy if you combine all of those
three steps
you find that you start with four
protons you produce
helium-4 positrons neutrinos
photons and energy
in fact as i was just saying
this all happens within the hot plasma
um
the positrons are basically annihilated
with electrons which are
part of the plasma adding another mev of
energy to this
all right this is one and the dominant
energy um
production mechanism within the sun but
also it's not the only one
also quite interesting is so-called
carbon cycle
it's contributing about three percent to
the sun's energy output
so here um carbon basically uh
works as a catalyst so you have a carbon
and
again a proton producing nitrogen the
nitrogen produces carbon 13 carbon 13
together with
a proton nitrogen 14 nitrogen 14 with
the proton
oxygen 15 and oxygen 15
nitrogen 15 and then last but not least
nitrogen 15 together with a proton
produces
carbon 12 again
and helium so you see that the carbon 12
is the catalyst here which is used to
produce helium
and energy so if you produce this cycle
that you would combine this cycle you
find that again from four
protons or what for hydrogen
atoms you produce helium positrons again
neutrinos three photons
and energy very similar it's still
visible to this
combined chain with the exception that
there is one additional photon and again
here
the positrons supply additional energy
and they annihilate with electrons
great so we have seen that we do two
things we create
heavier forms of matter starting from
hydrogen
and we produce energy and so this is the
energy production mechanism within the
sun
this is nice um you know you produce you
know you start with hydrogen or
deuterium
those are two elements which are very
abundant
and you produce energy so the question
comes up whether or not you can actually
use this
on earth in a controlled environment in
order to produce energy and solve many
of the
of the ongoing issues we have on this
planet
there are several efforts on the way and
this goes back all the way to the 50s
of the last century the most prominent
one currently is the so-called ita
project
which is an international collaboration
and the project where
one tries to build a fusion
reactor in france
um i can already tell you that the the
next stage for this
is in about five years to complete
the project or complete the production
of construction of the project
and produce energy for the first time
with this project
in this controlled environment it will
take another 10-15 years
on this roadmap of research in order to
produce
or be able to produce nuclear power
reactors
nuclear fusion power reactors which can
be used in some sort of commercial way
there's a few other interesting projects
which use different magnet technologies
which might
um have a more faster pathway to success
but coming back to the story here so
you could start with um with protons
again
in a proton proton reaction but it turns
out that this is a rather slow process
and not very promising for a
controlled reaction but deuterium or
trithium are also very promising
note that you know for deuterium here we
have to overcome the same coulomb
barrier right the charges are
charges involved are the very same but
the cross sections are higher
and therefore the likelihood for the
process to occur is higher and therefore
um this can this can happen much faster
um the theorem is again as i was saying
before very abundant you can just
extract this from water
tritium is a little bit more difficult
to deal with um to produce into control
and because it's radioactive and has
some
some really not so good features so this
is a model picture of ita
again this is an international project
um
it has a rather bad reputation these
days it's
it's by far the most expensive
scientific endeavor
but again i mean i think this is an
investment into the future of this
planet
and uh and hopefully will succeed in the
next years with this project and then
the long run with
having uh nuclear fission a fusion
available sorry nuclear fusion available
for energy creation what you see here is
the key feature of this reactor is
[Music]
toroidal magnets which confine the
plasma
and also electric fields are used in
order to heat the plasma up first so you
have to
provide heat to a point that you know
the heat being produced
in the fusion process is sufficient
to self-sustain and so that you know
confining the plasma and and
providing enough energy uh and the
radiation in this and so on this is all
very difficult
difficult problems to solve
you